[Applause]
there may be agony in england but
there's sheer
ecstasy in italy
[Applause]
the capitol room simply erupted
thousands turned out on the streets to
celebrate a win which was agonizing
incoming
an early goal for england and penalties
at the end
it may have taken more than 50 years of
waiting but italy are european champions
for a second time
[Applause]
this is a nation of football lovers and
this victory was all the sweeter
given italy failed to qualify for the
world cup in 2018
a change at the top and italy can now
boast of not losing a match in more than
30 games
[Music]
the team will now be fated in towns and
cities up and down the nation
and if these are the scenes post-match
what do the homecoming and victory
parade promise
they've adopted the england football
anthem here saying
football's coming rome and that
confidence and optimism proved to be
well-founded
the party in italy is only just getting
started
this is a nation celebrating a victory
fans believe is long overdue
and they intend to make the most of it
michelle clifford sky news
rome